resident evil 4 might be connected to
village and sony is ramping up ps5
production
the june 3rd playstation state of play
presentation had far more exciting
content than we expected including a
number of upcoming ps5 and psvr 2 games
it even included an unexpected pc
announcement for spider-man and a remake
of one of the most beloved resident evil
games resident evil 4. talk about a very
strong opener afterward capcom showed
off re village in vr and since we're on
the subject of village reddit user kaiju
media james pointed out a possible link
between re4 and re village kaiju wrote i
noticed this symbol in the re4r trailer
and it looks somewhat similar to the
four houses symbol in village another
user legitness compared an image of
sadler from the new re4 to one of
village's mother miranda what's extra
interesting about this frame of saddler
is that it comes right after the symbol
is shown so without spoiling anything
resident evil 4 takes place 20 years
before the events of village so it's
very possible that capcom is taking this
new opportunity to connect the two
timelines but once the resident evil
portion of the show was done sony went
on to show trailers for stray the
callisto protocol horizon call of the
mountain street fighter 6 and my
personal favorite roller drum
unfortunately there isn't enough info
available for me to talk about roller
drum for the rest of the video so
instead let's take a step back and talk
about street fighter 6 because capcom is
aiming to redefine the series with the
game's new gameplay mechanics all
fighters will have access to the drive
system a system of 5 special moves that
players can experiment with drive impact
is a powerful strike that can absorb an
opponent's incoming attack and send them
flying drive parry can repel an attack
and refill your drive gauge drive rush
also allows for the gap to be quickly
closed in between fighters drive
reversal adds counter attacks for when
you're pushed into a corner and each
character has an overdrive art that is
similar to ex moves from past games but
capcom didn't stop at re in sf to end
the show it popped up once again with an
action-packed look at final fantasy 16.
sometime after the stream the game's
official twitter account revealed a
handful of the development team
including final fantasy 14's composer
masayoshi sokin and with such an awesome
state of play those without a
playstation 5 might be yearning for one
even more than before if you happen to
fall into that category
i've got good news for you sony has
promised a significant ramp up in ps5
production for 2022 to help meet the
demand this nugget of info was revealed
to gi.biz by playstation executive
veronica rogers it was also revealed
that the playstation 5 has reached a new
sales milestone and surpassed 20 million
units sold since launch in november 2022
and since this video is all playstation
themed it seems like the perfect one to
mention abandoned the game from blue box
that faced a ton of backlash after
hinting at a connection to kojima and
silent hill our very own mark delaney
has a feature on the story behind what's
happening at blue box and i'm assigning
it to you all as homework for the
weekend the link will be in the
description and you all will be quizzed
come monday morning but other than that
hit the comment section and tell me what
game i should play this weekend but
please don't say anything too scary my
poor heart can't take it
[Music]